CU sandwiches are my favorite you know
what they don't even come from Cuba can
you believe
that okay well I'm sure you build up an
appetite carrying around that big gun y
let's go with this money I ain't trying
to be here all night wh we have
life what made you want to tell this
story yeah I think um you know I wanted
to represent my community I wanted to
represent the people that inhabit that
community and I think some sometimes
through media the Bronx and those people
can be portrayed in a negative light and
I felt an honor and a responsibility to
not only contradict those negative
stereotypes but showcase this place that
raised me and made me the artist and the
man that I am today and um you know it
was just from that from representing my
community my people the things that made
me in a way that I had never seen
depicted on the big screen before Lizzy
um you know you've worked on some
amazing films we were talking earlier
about you worked on Shiva baby but what
was it about story a that kind of made
your ears perk up what was it about that
appealed to you um well uh I loved the
script obviously uh I thought the
characters were so beautiful and I
thought it was just this uh kind of
Timeless story of how one act of
kindness can really change someone's
life the thing that really made me want
to make this movie is the scene in the
dark room between Gloria and Kadir when
they're talking about uh making art that
feels authentic versus making art that
needs to be able to sustain in a
capitalist system and I just thought it
would be amazing to play a scene like
that for a room full of people who love
movies um and I just think it asks a
really important question especially
right now definitely right
now um uh for for for Eric you know you
know working together with Aristotle how
what kind of vibe and mood were you
looking to create when it came to
framing this you know very traditional
but like more modernized Mentor mentee
you know
narrative yeah um you know I think the
vibe we were trying to give was truth
much like Aristotle said you know I mean
he's from the Bronx I'm from the Bronx
uh it film has not always been kind to
us uh and we're trying to change that um
so you know that's what uh that's what
we're really trying to portray and um as
far as framing goes you know we decided
to go with a 4x3 ratio um for a couple
reasons one because of the verticality
of the of the world and of the story of
the of you know these kind of small
characters framed by these large you
know uh murals and walls um and then
also you know it's a story about our
main character gadir qu not quite
knowing his place and
so especially in group group settings
like the first time he goes to OTL we
were really able to kind of isolate
Kadir in the frame uh using 4x3 in a way
that we couldn't if we were shooting
widescreen you know this movie is coming
out uh during the 50th anniversary of
Hip Hop and um uh you know what is your
connection to hip hop and how do you
think it has contributed to your voice
as an artist you know one of my favorite
Jay-Z lines is like I wear my do-rag to
the Grammys to represent you and I just
love that line I love being true to
yourself and being authentic and Hip Hop
really taught me that and I cut my teeth
you know making music videos I learned
how to become a director and how to run
a set and be resourceful and and you
know and have minimal resources and time
and that all came from from hip-hop and
making music videos so I felt like I owe
a lot to hip-hop and it was an honor to
represent that part of the culture in
this film how does this movie speak to
each of you to where you are in your
career right now and how do you think it
speaks to where we are in kind of like
Society or the world I don't know that's
a very broad question but let's
try go that way this way no you got it
er um don't be shy uh this movie I mean
for me career-wise was a chance to kind
of get back to smaller film making I've
been doing some like larger TV shows um
um and I really really jumped at the
chance to be able to collaborate with a
small team and make something that was
really really really uh true to our
initial Vision um which was a gift um so
that's what this movie meant to be um
and also just you know in general
representation you know being able to
shoot in the neighborhood where I'm from
is not something that happens often and
it's which is really really
special um this movie was a great chance
for me to kind of continue something
I've been trying to do which is support
underrepresented voices um definitely
big opportunities in terms of
representation on screen and I also just
love films that allow you to sort of
ingratiate yourself in a community that
you otherwise are on the outside of and
get to gain new understanding that way
and um we worked with a lot of really
amazing graph artists and really um
especially Aristotle uh nestled oursel
in their community and kind of by their
rules and that's always such an
interesting and fun challenge to me when
making a movie when you need to rely
heavily on a community um and also
respect kind of doing things their way
because as movie people we love to come
in and be like this is how it's getting
done um and I'm just so happy a movie
like this exists especially right now
because I think it's getting harder and
harder to make these sort of like
intimate dramas and see them SU suceed
in our market and allow them to have
theatrical moments and I'm so grateful
to Kino lber who has really allowed us
to have that sort of moment in um such a
crazy kind of time so yeah all of those
things yeah and similarly you know at
least for me you know this
film taught me that I can make movies
you know this is my first movie and um
you know coming from music videos and
commercials it's a different part of
your brain as a director you know I
spent my first 20 years directing
staring at a monitor making sure it's in
focus and the camera's moving at the
right speed and um you know I think the
biggest takeaway from Sundance that
really helped me make this film is my
job as a filmmaker is to protect the
film and craft performances and this
film taught me that with a lot of hard
work and sacrifice and focus I could I
can make a career of this how was it
like for you to see the film for the
first time in a theater with an audience
what was that experience like for you
well is that South by Guess uh no we did
some screens before South by I mean to
be completely transparent I just started
having non-hate watches fairly recently
so um it's all new I mean I'm an artist
and um you know you make three movies
you make the one you write the one you
shoot and the one you put in the world
and the one you put in the world is the
most important um and that in itself is
a process and um but yeah you know it's
it's seriously it's it's really
interesting and inspiring and some of
the most gratifying moments I've had
thus far people from this community
specifically who are normally not
allowed to feel vulnerable coming up to
me after the movie crying saying that
like they've never seen themselves on
the big screen before and this was
really hard to make but it's those
things that justify that you know to
make people feel seen is such a
privilege and an honor well well going
off of that that I think this would be
kind of a good way to wrap up um um for
each of you what do you hope people take
away from from story
AV yeah well I think good you know good
movies allow the viewer to challenge
themselves and the world around them um
and the world should feel different when
you walk out of the theater from a film
and I hope that this film offers A New
Perspective on graffiti and the
sacrifice these artists make of their
freedom in their life in order to
express themselves
artistically and I hope that this film
shows you that people who are in really
tough
circumstances could just be a byproduct
of really bad luck not necessarily from
bad choices how about you
Lizzy um I think for me it sort of goes
back to this these acts of kindness and
that the love we show each other in the
world makes all of the difference um and
also and this is something Aristotle
talks about a lot too is just chosen
family about how you build a community
around you and how those influences can
also really change the direction of your
life cool and last but not least Eric um
I hope people take away from this that
art can come from anywhere good artists
are everywhere around you good artists
are serving your coffee pumping your gas
waiting tables uh each of those people
you know I'm sure has a story to tell
and is probably one of the greatest
artists of their generation any just
never
know well Aristotle Lizzie Eric thank
you all so much thank give them a round
of applause uh thank you for creating
this movie tell everyone about it and
thank you for joining us tonight yeah
thank you so much have a good evening
appreciate it guys thank
you